und mit einem militärexperten wollen wir
jetzt sprechen über die aktuelle
situation in der ukraine egon ramms ist
da general ag einer der höchsten nato
generale gewesen
ich grüße sie und wir haben eben die
situation gesehen in mario pohl viele
sagen ja dass mario puzo ein bisschen
symbolcharakter auch hart also wenn
mario pohl fällt dann entscheidet sich
hier das schicksal der ukraine wie sehen
sie das guten morgen frau davis ich
glaube dass dieser ansatz in nach meiner
bewertung an wird etwas übertrieben ist
ich glaube die ukraine wissen
mittlerweile dass die streitkräfte
angeht aber auch die zivilbevölkerung
angeht dass der kampf um die ukraine
weiter geht mario pohl ist sicherlich
ein symbol keine frage aber neue pool
fallen sollte was ich ja auch schon
jetzt über 14 tage zwischen den
meldungen der russischen seite die ja
immer wieder sagen wir haben sondern
haben sie es doch nicht und der
ukrainischen seite abspielt dürfte nicht
die entscheidende rolle sollen ich denke
dass die ukraine mit dem gleichen willen
mit dem gleichen mut weiter kämpfen
werden wie sie es bisher gemacht haben
von daher wäre das besten fall so ein
kleines zwischenziel für die russen aber
ich wiederhole das was gerade im bericht
auch schon drin war es ist noch nicht
genommen und neben dem
stahlwerk gibt es noch einen weiteren
teil im westen von mario pohl der
ebenfalls noch umkämpft ist von daher
abwarten wie die sache weitergeht aber
es begründet auch ein bisschen warum die
ukraine die ganze zeit nach schweren
waffen fragt oder diese partie fordert
wenn man mario palette entsetzen wollen
hätte man dafür gepanzerte fahrzeuge
panzern dergleichen gebraucht davon hat
die ukraine offensichtlich zu wenig
sodass das nicht gelungen ist gehen wir
mal in die nächste region die donbass
region wo ja so meldet es zumindest die
ukrainische seite dann die offensive die
russische offensive begonnen hat auch
hier fehlt es ja wie wie überall in der
ukraine an schwerem gerät und ist eine
waffenlieferung eingetroffen offenbar
aus den usa da hat es geheißen meldungen
aber auch jetzt sollen erst mal das
ukrainische militär eingewiesen werden
in den gebrauch dieser gerätschaften
wenn man sich die akute situation also
da gibt es akute angriff situationen
jetzt und und dann auf der anderen seite
die den stand der waffenlieferung
anschaut wie beurteilen sie da die
situation auf ukrainischer seite also
aus ukrainischer sollte die ukraine hat
einen dringenden bedarf an schweren
waffen systemen das sind panzer das im
schützenpanzer das sind vor allen dingen
auch abläufe geschützte die amerikaner
jetzt liefern
leider ist es so dass die systeme aus
sowjetischer bauzeit oder von russischer
herkunft eine völlig andere technik
haben als unsere waffen sie haben unsere
man nicht die amerikaner war auch die
deutschen mit dass es eine situation so
dass die ukrainischen soldaten die diese
waffen bedienen sollen zumindest an
diesem gerät eingewiesen werden müssen
das ist eine relativ kurze einweisung
aber sie muss stattfinden damit sie
überhaupt in der lage sind diese waffen
sicher bedienen zu können und auch die
strebten ziele damit dann entsprechend
bekämpfen zu können wenn sie sagen aber
relativ kurzer einweisung dann höre ich
das macht trotzdem sinn zumindest aus
ukrainischer sich diese waffen jetzt zu
erhalten um sie dann kurzfristig auch
einsetzen zu können vd bis der krieg in
der ukraine ist ja nicht auch mit der
einnahme des neuen pass beispielsweise
wo die justiz darauf abzielen nicht zu
ende soll wird weitergehen das heißt
alles was an schweren waffen alle riege
schützenpanzern schützenpanzern in die
ukraine rein läuft und von denen
eingesetzt werden kann ist für die
ukrainische streitkräfte von vorteil
dass die situation die wir haben und
wenn die ukraine irgendwann mal
geländegewinne erzielen wollen oder
gelände zurückerobern wollen dann
brauchen sie dafür schwere waffen
während sie die verteidigungs gefechte
im regelfall ich sag mal mit leichter
infanterie oder infanterie führen können
die mit entsprechenden waffen auch aus
dem westen ich erinnere an die
panzerfaust sich die flieger fäuste
entsprechend bekämpfen können und
hierbei spielt eine von amerika von usa
gelieferte drohne swiss plate auch noch
eine besondere rolle insbesondere
ballett man zu beginn vor
wir haben mario pohl besprochen donbass
jetzt hat es ja über die ostertage im
prinzip im ganzen land aber weitere
angriffe gegeben also auch im westen des
landes lemberg in der hauptstadt kiew
zuerst ein bisschen der rückzug der der
russischen truppen und jetzt aber dann
doch wieder auch angriffe in der fläche
was will will moskau damit ausdrücken
welche strategie weiterverfolgt also
moskau betont hier aber diesen beschuss
sage ich mal sei es mit raketen
mittlerer jetzt wieder in kiew oder
beispielsweise in dem bereich mit
raketen ganz deutlich die tatsache dass
sie immer militärische ziele bekämpfen
was nicht der fall ist wir sehen das an
den täglichen bildern die über die
sender laufen das immer wieder zivile
ziele sei es krankenhäuser schulen und
andere dinge beschlossen werden und auf
diese art und weise will man im prinzip
ich sag das mal einer terror gegenüber
der zivilbevölkerung verbreiten und der
zivilbevölkerung auf der anderen seite
signalisieren wir können euch überall in
eurem eigenen land erreichen und das ist
sicherlich auch keine positive wirkung
wie man die reaktionen der
zivilbevölkerung selber merkt von daher
hat dieses auch ich sag das mal an
moralischen faktoren die moralisierende
wirkung wir sprechen gleich weiter vor
allen dingen auch über das thema nochmal
die debatte um deutsche
waffenlieferungen in die ukraine und in
der ost ukraine werden gerade schwere
waffen benötigt haben wir eben schon
besprochen mit egon ramms general ade
wir sprechen jetzt weiter über die
debatte hier vor allen dingen auch in
deutschland die innenpolitische bislang
hat der bundeskanzler olaf scholz sicher
sehr bedeckt gehalten es wurde jetzt
noch mal die militärhilfe ordentlich
aufgestockt also statt waffen erst mal
gelte was kann die ukraine damit im
moment anfangen also mit diesem geld
kann die ukraine möglicherweise bei
anderen ländern waffen kaufen käuflich
erwerben wobei sich das im augenblick
meiner kenntnis entzieht ich habe da
keinen überblick welche länder in der
lage wären jetzt kurzfristig waffen an
die ukraine zu liefern diese diskussion
muss in deutschland glaube ich noch mal
wiederbelebt werden der besuch der drei
vertreter der drei parteien spd grüne
und fdp in der ende vergangener woche
ende vorvergangener woche hat ja sehr
deutlich gezeigt dass diese den eindruck
mitgebracht haben dass die ukraine
schwere waffen haben muss es gibt also
eine ich sag das mal in der regierung
fraktionsübergreifende position und
irgendwann muss zu diesem thema eine
entscheidung gefällt werden zwar eine
entscheidung dass auch deutschland sich
entscheidet für waffen an die ukraine
abzugehen im rahmen des möglichen
mit auch einer mindestens kurzen
ausbildung und einweisung und auch der
entsprechende munition mit dabei das
kann nur passieren mit hilfe der
deutschen industrie weil zum teil diese
waffen im besitz von industriefirmen
sind und in jedem falle durch die
industrie in stand gesetzt werden müssen
und das muss dann alles sehr sehr
schnell gehen man hätte diese
entscheidung vielleicht vor sechs oder
sieben wochen film ja auch da wieder der
der konjunktiv wir sie haben es eben
angesprochen es gibt stimmen aus der fdp
auch von den grünen anton hofreiter war
ja auch in der ukraine
allein der bundeskanzler und die spd
halten sich zurück denken sie ein besuch
vor ort von bundeskanzler scholz könnte
da einfluss haben auf seine meinung auf
seine entscheidung denn die kolleginnen
aus dem aus dem bundestag waren ja eben
auch vor ort und kam ja offenbar sehr
beeindruckt dann wieder zurück ich weise
darauf hin dass bei diesem besuch auch
roth von der spd mit dabei waren sich ja
gleich lautend wie frau agnes strack
zimmermann und anton hofreiter geäußert
hat von daher sage ich mal ist die
meinung zumindest in der spd nicht eine
einheitliche meinung im sinne von
kanzler meinung sondern da gibt es
durchaus andere auffassung jetzt gab es
heute aus reihen der fdp noch eine
stimme der designierte generalsekretär
bijan djir sarai hat sich dahingehend
geäußert dass er sagt er erwartet eine
entscheidung über die lieferung schwerer
waffen in den kommenden tagen was für
ein signal hören wir da raus also
zumindest höre ich das signal daraus
dass die fdp offensichtlich relativ
geschlossen für die lieferung schwerer
waffen steht sie ist regierungspartei
mit also kann sich in der regierung auch
entsprechend ihre stimme erheben und ich
sage das ganz einfach ich hoffe dass
olaf scholz und der bundeskanzler mit
daran denkt dass die freiheit europas so
zahlt denn der ukraine verteidigt wird
und zu europa gehört deutschland glaube
ich auch ja klar und auch zur nato sie
waren ja nun auch bei der nato tätig wir
haben es gehört usa auch nato partner
hat waffen geliefert ich frag jetzt mal
aus der anderen richtung ist es dann
aber vor diesem hintergrund dass man
sagt die wir erhalten uns raus als als
nato aus dieser ganzen geschichte und
gleichzeitig aber liefern dann einzelne
länder waffen dorthin ist das nicht auf
irgendeine art und weise auch in
konsequent also es gibt eine rechtliche
diskussion darüber ob die lieferung von
waffen bereits die kriegsteilnahme
begründet ja oder nein ich bin der
auffassung dass das nicht der fall ist
wenn waffen geliefert werden von daher
wird die die grenze die sich die nato
selber gesetzt hat nur dann zu reagieren
wenn nato territorium angegriffen wird
wird dadurch nicht überschritten
eindeutige worte vielen dank ramms für
heute morgen ich danke gerne